now I'm interested to know your reaction
to those local elections because what we
saw was kind of areas of the country
that have been you know labor for many
years turning blue at places like
Nottingham share for example where lots
of people sort switched the
Conservatives what do you think is
happening why do you think that is I
think they know that Labour is
absolutely busted it can offer them
nothing and people are turning to us a
lot of it is because of Teresa made it
is as simple as that they trust her as a
leader they like what they see and they
have no doubt that she's the only person
that can't just get us a deal in brexit
but actually build us a great future for
our economy beyond brexit and people get
that that's what I'm getting back from
the doorstep I've actually not heard one
bad word against Tereza mate and yes I
do knock on all doors in all areas it's
fascinating
people trust her they like her and they
think she's dare I say strong and stable
leadership but can we make a deal the
last time you say it's not Wednesday
Polly solutely I don't really you know
what I really object to the idea no
disrespect to you that Britain's media
now decides whether or not parties can
use slogans oh wait I don't we don't
leave we haven't seem to be doing a very
good job of it given the amount of times
the strongest tables being wheeled out
parties in all elections have slogans
have you ever said anything against Tony
Blair when he was using slogans in 1997
people who will decide ladies go but
Tony Blair's slogans back in 1997 nobec
whether it be they really matter in this
and people actually watching this people
who will vote or maybe not late but
people who elect us they are the only
people that matter and no disrespect to
you of course I can really but I think
Britain's media really kind of needs to
get a grip on who and what they are it's
people that matter not the media okay
well I'm sorry that you dis included me
from a slur on my colleagues but anyway
and now the other thing that we saw in
those locals was the Conservatives
hoovering up an awful lot of former UK
voters now someone who is one of the
most loud pro-eu voices in your own
party does that make you a bit
uncomfortable that the kind of nature of
your party
changing and the nature of my party is
not changing are you sure absolutely
and I'm confident of that because I'm
confident in Teresa mayor who is a one
nation conservative I remember the words
that she used on Downing Street on the
evening that she moved in and I have I
feel very secure in her leadership look
a lot of those UK voters in this county
we're of course a neighbor voters and
the interesting thing is is that they've
not returned to the neighbor fold
they're coming to the conservative form
so and I look at a town like Eastwood
which is very much like my own hometown
of works up in north Nottingham sure a
mining town eastward voted conservative
I mean it is astonishing that we won
east work a mining a Pitt villa at Pitt
turn on this car one of the big reasons
one of the big reasons these former UK
photos or many of them as you say come
from labor some from the Conservatives
previously and one of the big reasons
they're lining up behind tourism a is
because they trust her to deliver what
they want to see on brexit which is
something that you don't agree with
their views you don't think that we
should be coming out of the single
market you don't think that we should be
playing hard all oh look don't kid
yourself that all those you Kip voters
all of them man and woman said we don't
want to be in the single market we want
this doesn't work like that at all and
and I don't think they want what some
people are describing a hard brings
negligence how I know that cannot say
that any everybody that voted Lee for
all you Kipp voters don't want to be in
the single market or don't want this
happen the other because they come in
all shapes and sizes with all views what
they are United about is that's leaving
the EU and what I'm getting from the
doorstep and it is different if I may
say to London that's why they it's
brilliant that you're here and you're
not trapped in that London bubble is
that here what people want actually is
just to move on now and the idea that
you will remain an or reliever your
this'll you're in or out actually people
are moving on they've accepted like me
the result that's indeed Margaret
Beckett was saying she and I don't agree
very much we didn't want us to be in
this position but we are where we are
and now we've got to get the very best
deal and there's only one person who is
going to stand any chance of getting
that good deal and that's too easily you
say that and this week it does fit
as though relationships between number
tan and Brussels have somewhat become
fraught shall we say it applied we're
putting it to reasonably effectively
accused Brussels of meddling in the EU
election in the UK election I mean that
might win her some votes on the doorstep
it might be a good way of attracting you
kid voters but it's not great
negotiating strategies it we're not
negotiating at them as he's gone we are
negotiating so we're not actually in the
negotiating strategy in most
circumstances at the moment no these are
opening salvos it's like those boxes
that you know they do all that stuff
before they actually get in the really
long term though with it's not gonna be
some constants with those negotiation
starts not what wanna sleep I just think
that this is a bit of a puff and we are
in a general election and say the proc I
mean I wouldn't have used those terms
but the point Minister is she's getting
out there she wants to win well there's
nothing wrong with that and so she's
doing what she can to gather people
behind her to get a good result and then
move on into those negotiations when all
sorts of things will have to change
because that's the nature of
negotiations and it's going to be tough
that's why Teresa maze the only person
who can do it now it's reported that the
government is working on a strategy what
should happen if there is no deal and I
think sent from the legs on the language
coming out is jean-claude young his
office perhaps indicates that that is
look something that's looking
increasingly likely do you still think
that that is a bad idea if there is no
deal oh yeah we want to deal as Theresa
May said she wants to deal as well and
no deal would be a very bad deal in my
opinion I don't de mer from that at all
if Theresa May does get the majority
that many people expect at the election
your influence is going to be reduced
doesn't it see well if you think about
it does feel sometimes to outsider is a
conservative back benches are kind of
providing a sort of unofficial
opposition to some of the policies well
that's because we've got such a useless
labor party I mean you should not
underestimate the concern on the
doorstep that people have about the
state of the labor party a you are item
as it as well what the late oh yeah
because you want a good opposition you
want a good strong opposition
Suda is important for our democracy and
you know people get that but they are
not they on they are by no means foolish
about this they see the Labour Party
forty days and it is in the most
terrible state and it's a state of their
own making so what you'll see in this
election is you'll see Labour MPs who
are desperate to cling on for
understandable reasons and they will be
saying on the doorstep we've already
seen it here in Nottingham south where
Lilian Greenwood is the incumbent Labour
MP and the slogan is vote local vote
Labour vote lilium and you will see that
all over the country they will say as
they did in the local elections oh don't
worry about Jeremy Corbyn it's not about
Jeremy Coleman it's all about friend or
freedom whoever the Labour candidate is
it's about them and people are not
stupid they know it's not about that
it's about who do you want as your prime
minister do you want Jeremy Corbyn or
Theresa May and overwhelmingly they'll
say Theresa May and I think also people
get this thing about her having a
mandate it's not just about brexit a
mandate for for herself as our prime
minister to have our own clear mandate
makes complete sense to be elected as a
prime minister on a manifesto we can all
rally behind if she does become elected
as a prime minister and increase her
majority as the polls of the local
election suggests she will you've said
you're worried about the state of labour
that they're not providing any
opposition your ability as a
conservative back-bencher to provide
that scrutiny and opposition will also
be diminished because she can
effectively ignore you want things like
brexit or grammar schools because she
will have enough people to get those
votes through Parliament so that can't
be good for democracy I don't agree at
all I think other Conservative Party has
always been a broader church but there
is this unity behind her to get this
good brexit deal and people like me will
continue to scrutinize and ask questions
on behalf of our constituents but the
idea that the right will take away not
the case I think that part of the
decision for her to cause a call this
general election and to get a good
healthy majority which is good for
government actually is because she will
want to see off some of those elements
within the Conservative Party who do
want that hard brexit which she doesn't
want so I think it strengthens her hand
within the party and in the
parliamentary party and I have no
difficulty with that at all she's a one
nation Tory like I am you say that it
strengthens her hands against the bricks
or tears or the rice that a hard-line
right of the parties is maybe you would
describe it but it also mean she doesn't
have to worry so much about pesky
rebellions from the more centrist and
people yourself as well realistic side
does a some extent but then you know
people like me you know and I think that
I have a very happy home in the Tory
party my politics you may think submit
sad but my politics hasn't changed for
40 odd years has your party's politics
changed they actually have improved
considerably in my time absolutely and
they changed actually the person who
began to lay those foundations was
Theresa May when she was chairman of the
Conservative Party she brought more
women in she started the reforms that
made us more electable in due course
David Cameron came in and he made us as
well electable and now she is continuing
that great work now I'm interested to
know your thoughts about the election
campaign so far we've seen almost like a
policy a day from Labour we've got a new
one of the newspapers this morning about
Tax Jeremy Corbyn has been taking lots
of questions giving interviews from the
Conservatives so it almost feels as
though you're just not doing very much
at all there's been not many policies
Theresa May hasn't been doing very many
interviews do you think that that is a
good way to treat the Electra because it
makes sense
I've almond a perspective of you know
not doing very much and hopefully
coasting a very people who aren't
assaulting their voters doesn't it no
it's not the only because we're on the
doorstep every day but what are you
saying no other policy is really
importantly so out in the real world out
there we're on the doorstep every day
unlike labour I might add because they
can't get the people out to knock on the
doors in the way that we are well there
was really no nick but of course they
would but that's where they look at the
results but that's where you win and
lose elections and I think it is
brilliant that finally after years of
these dreadful election campaigns where
somebody feels that
every day you've got to make a statement
and all over the country people are
yawning it it's great for you guys
because it gives you footage and it
gives you copy and everything else but
in the real world it turns people off
and I think her strategy of speaking
only when she's got something important
to say is fabulous and it's refreshing
and I'm also delighted that we're not
having those dreadful TV debates I'm
sorry it doesn't help you guys because
it means you've got holes in your shells
and so on and so forth but for people
out there I think they love it and the
real world millions and she won't use in
other TV debates have made disagree with
mainly at nerve millions more didn't
tune in and the highlight of a hybrid so
bad was in the referendum campaign I
mean it was a bleak moment it wasn't
your side of your channel that staged
that dreadful debate and from ain't from
Wembley wasn't it on the BBC and it was
a it was a very it was the lowest moment
ever in British politics laughs it was
ghastly it was it was critical stuff so
put it on the stub on the doorstep
that's where this debate this election
we won a lot and that's how Theresa May
campaigns and she'll be really happy to
enter there thank you Anna Siri